et
[Musique]
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous arthur
des nouveaux bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau merci d'être là vous êtes
le président de l'aïe fort parisse
association de victimes des attentats du
13 novembre 2015 vous étiez vous même ce
13 novembre 2015 dans la salle de
concert du bataclan vous êtes partie
civile au procès des responsables
présumés qui a commencé le 8 septembre
dernier la journée d'hier arthur des
nouveaux a été marqué et vous y étiez
par un nouvel interrogatoire de salah
abdeslam cette fois sur son rôle présumé
dans le préparatifs des attaques entre
silence et dénégations ça a été une
journée particulièrement électrique qui
s'est soldée par le départ des avocats
de la défense
comment avez-vous comment comprenez-vous
ce qui s'est passé hier côté c'est une
journée on a enfin vu très clairement la
ligne de défense de salles abdeslam qui
est de dire écoutez moi j'ai peut-être
participé aux préparatifs mais c'était à
l'insu de mon plein gré je me suis
finalement décidé à participer à quelque
chose quelques jours avant j'ai rien
fait et
à la fin j'ai décidé de ne pas me faire
sauter et donc en fait il va livrer
aucune information il a livré aucune
information qui peut le compromettre lui
mais il va même pas expliquer ce qui
s'est passé il va même pas comme il le
dit lui même parlait des morts et dire
ce qu'ils ont pu faire et donc on sait
maintenant qu'il n'ya aucune vérité à
attendre de salades des slams et
évidemment ça ça crée une tension et
cette tension encore été exacerbée par
le fait que salah abdeslam avait jean
reprend les mots je crois du figaro
aujourd'hui une défense de petits
dealers ou en plus il explique qu'il est
innocent qu'on lui a brisé sa vie et
qu'on a brisé la vie des autres gens
dans le box ça a suscité quelques
réactions dans la salle mais vraiment
pas nombreuses quelques applaudissements
et ça a suffi à ce que la défense s'en
servent pour faire un incident
la ligne de défense sociale à abdeslam
qui est sur une ligne de crête donc vous
venez de le dire ça colle pas vraiment
avec les éléments du dossier non alors
après c'est un procès très long il ya du
saucissonnage et donc on l'a pas encore
mis face à tous les éléments qu'on a on
l'a pas encore mis face aux images de
vidéosurveillance des stations service
la veille des attentats on l'a pas mis
face aux photos de son gilet explosif et
est donc pour l'instant il a beau jeu de
dire attendez on parle de août à
novembre moi j'ai rien faire ce moment
là et si j'ai qu'on voyait des gens
s'étaient pensant ramener des gens qui
fuyaient le conflit sérieux voilà il est
soupçonné fortement d'avoir arrêté
notamment entre autres choses le
chauffeur des commandos à leur arrivée
en hongrie et en allemagne on sent que
plus on approche du fou mais c'est le
cas depuis le début du procès plus la
pression médiatique est forte aussi sur
ses journées en particulier plus la
tension monte dans la cour d'assises
ouais évidemment
c'est très très long comme procès c'est
vraiment très long et on tourne un peu
autour du pot alors on sent que la
machine avance mais maintenant qu'on va
aborder les faits qu'on va aborder la
nuit du 13 novembre ça doit se passer
dans deux semaines évidemment la
pression monte et le chemin de crête
dont vous parlais à l'instant il est de
plus en plus difficile à tenir pour les
accusés principaux et leurs avocats hier
salah abdeslam par son agressivité à un
peu montré qu'il n'arrivait pas à tenir
la distance là dessus et ses avocats ont
finalement préféré couper court à la
journée plutôt que de voir leurs accusé
marquer des buts contre son camp le
procès censé se terminer fin juin sans
compter le délai d'appel ça fera dix
mois de procédure est les débats ont
déjà été reporté quatre fois je crois à
cause de 4 kovy notamment parmi elle est
prévenue -selon vous le disiez c'est
éprouvant on imagine pour tout le monde
mais pour les parties civiles en
particulier parce qu'il faut à chaque
fois aussi se remobilise et se remette
dedans oui et surtout on avait abordé le
procès je pense avec des attentes assez
limité en se disant mon toute façon les
accusés parleront pas il parle jamais
finalement ils ont commencé à parler et
on s'est pris au jeu quelque part hélas
ce qui est très fatiguant c'est de voir
qu'en fait ça va mener à rien et de voir
qui aura sûrement aucune réponse à nos
questions et que donc c'est dix mois
très important évidemment pour la
justice pour la démocratie mais que nous
on va rester avec nos questions et nos
douleurs à la fin et on sent une
certaine lassitude chez les parties
civiles qui se disent bon c'est très
bien on fait tout ça et après et après
en fait ce sera terminé mais nous on
restera avec notre roma et avec des
choses à faire qui vont au delà du
procès il y aurait à l'avenir la vérité
judiciaire en ça est ce qu'elle peut
aider d'une certaine façon oui la vérité
judiciaire à l'aide parce que c'est
quand même la vérité d'une justice
démocratique face à la barbarie et on
sent une grande fierté que la justice
puisse passer ensuite les
questionnements des familles endeuillées
qui se demandent pourquoi tel lieu
pourquoi
ce jour-là et ainsi de suite ça on sait
qu'on n'aura jamais les réponses on le
comprend maintenant et on l'a compris
encore mieux hier ses huit dates ces
sept derniers mois la cour d'assises
spéciale a recueilli les témoignages des
rescapés dont vous êtes de leur famille
amener le parcours des djihadistes
auditionner les enquêteurs pas que
français les grands témoins jusqu'à
demain normalement si la défense revient
elle va cependant elle se penche sur les
éléments matériels on a dit donc sur ce
qu'ils ont fait dès des prévenus et les
intendants de la terreur pour reprendre
une expression dont confrères du monde
est-ce que vous à titre personnel ou
auprès des autres parties civiles que
vous connaissez vous avez quand même
l'impression que ces débats jusqu'ici
ont permis de peut-être lever quelques
zones d'ombré ces débats nous ont permis
de comprendre oui un certain nombre de
choses
déjà on comprend un peu mieux quels sont
les mécanismes de propagande qui pousse
des jeunes comme ça à aller sur le front
à vouloir commettre des attentats on
comprend qu'il ya un mélange de religion
et de politique qui était pas aussi
clair au début du procès donc ça c'est
assez important on comprend aussi que
dans leur vision c'était des frappes
défensives plutôt que des frappe
offensive même si c'est complètement
contestée par le calendrier donc ça
quelque part ça je précise eux disent
qu'ils ont agi notamment pour pour
répondre à ce qui se passait en syrie
est exactement pour répondre aux frappes
de la coalition alors qu'on voit que les
premiers attentats sur le sol européen
notamment le musée juif et ben ça c'est
bien avant les premières frappes voilà
donc on voit que c'est pas vrai ça nous
permet quand même de comprendre un peu
leur psychologie mais il reste des zones
d'ombré évidemment sur le 13 novembre
les mêmes pourquoi quel choix des lieux
et ainsi de suite mais aussi sur qu'est
ce qui fait que ces jeunes qui pour une
grande partie d'entre eux en fait sont
pas du tout des gangsters de carrière
n'ont pas vraiment de casiers
judiciaires des parcours de vie
relativement normaux si on prend
quelqu'un comme ça là des slams il a des
délits routiers et une participation un
soir un cambriolage ou c'est pas lui qui
l'a fait de manière principale c'est pas
du tout un an durci qu'est ce qui fait
que lui bascule à un moment ça on
n'arrive pas à le comprendre et là
dessus et nous éclaire pas non plus ça
hélas des frustrations il vous faut vous
faire le deuil d'avoir la réponse à
cette question probablement il nous faut
faire le deuil d'un certain nombre de
choses ce qui est bien c'est que on sait
qu'on s'est donné le temps on sait qu'on
s'est donné les moyens on sera donné dix
mois et donc les réponses qu'on n'aura
pas eu là on sait qu'on les aura pas
vous payer pour que soient diffusés à
l'audience et vous êtes loin d'être tous
d'accord parmi les parties civiles des
images et les sons et qui ont été
captées au bataclan car il y en a le
soir du 13 novembre pourquoi est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est important et
qu'est ce que vous pensez que ça peut
apporter au débat alors il ya plusieurs
choses déjà on se concentre sur le
bataclan parce qu en fait des images ont
été montrées des autres le bataclan il
ya une espèce de tabous autour et si on
regarde l'ordonnancé de mise en
accusation on parle bien de complicité
d'assassinats terroristes et ça nous
paraît normal que ces assassinats
quelque part soit montré il ya deux
choses qui nous paraissent importantes
la première c'est que c'est important
pour les survivants il ya des gens qui
sont restés deux heures dans cette fosse
qui ont envie de se souvenir qu'ils
veulent savoir si leurs souvenirs
correspondent à une certaine réalité et
ce qui n'a pas beaucoup été dit c'est
qu'en fait l'audio du bataclan est
certes au dossier mais dans un scellé et
donc les pertes civiles n'y ont pas
accès même avec leurs avocats et est
donc une envie de voir ça il ya aussi
une envie de montrer ce qui nous est
arrivé de montrer les conséquences du
terrorisme et que si on se donne dix
mois pour juger on soit capable de
regarder ces images en face
effectivement il n'y a pas de consensus
sur le fait de montrer ces images nous
ce qu'on propose c'est que leur
diffusion soit acté bien en avance pour
que les gens qui veulent pas venir et
qu'ils soient choqués ne viennent pas
mais ça nous paraît important 1 pour la
vérité judiciaire et il ya toujours
c'est vrai ce maigre espoir que ça fasse
bouger quelque chose chez les accusés on
verra si c'est le cas précisément vous
le disiez avant le procès que vous aviez
le sentiment que ce processeur est je
vous cite en davantage le procès de la
rencontre entre les victimes et le
système judiciaire de la société que
celui entre les victimes et leurs
bourreaux est ce que c'est moi si vous
ont confirmé ce que vous pensiez si vous
regardez bien ça fait donc six mois ou
un peu plus qu on confesse procès il n'y
a pas de parole directe entre
les victimes et les accusés au moment
des témoignages des victimes on a pu
dire quelques mots si on voulait
certains n'ont fait les accusés ont dit
je vais parler un peu à cause de tel ou
tel témoignage mais on n'est pas du tout
dans la justice restaurative en france
et finalement les parties civiles n'ont
plus la parole depuis quatre mois et
demi alors que c'est maintenant que les
accusés parle et donc c'est vraiment pas
la rencontre entre les accusés et leurs
gros en plus la géographie de la salle
fait que c'est pas possible de
s'approcher du box que là où si vous
regardez pour saint-etienne du rouvray
et on vous dit que les parties civiles
soit allé parler à certains des gens
dans le box chez nous c'est simplement
pas possible pour des raisons de
sécurité et donc c'est beaucoup plus les
parties civiles parlent à la cour les
accusés par la cour et aux avocats mais
en tout cas il n'y a pas de parole
directe le procès de l'assassinât du
père ahmed à l'issue duquel
effectivement il ya eu des moments très
forts mais on n'est jamais à l'abri que
quelque chose comme ça se passe non mais
effectivement je vais à l'abri vous
disiez aussi et pour revenir peut-être
sur les arguments que vous disiez pour
que soient diffusés ces sons captés au
bataclan encore avant le procès que être
victimes de terrorisme c'était le summum
de la passivité est ce que ces mois de
débats ces moments de témoignages
éventuellement l'importance que vous
accordez à la diffusion de ces sombres
pour dire aussi pour rappeler ce qui
vous était arrivé à tous permet tout on
permis une forme de réappropriation
c'est exactement ça et c'est bien ça
l'idée c'est qu'on veut pas être des
parties civiles qui regardent le train
passer et qui ne se mêlent pas de ce qui
se dit donc effectivement on avait un
temps dévolu ces cinq semaines pour
aller témoigner qui doit être complétée
d'une autre semaine de témoignage mais
on essaye aussi vraiment de dire ce qui
est important pour nous dans le procès
de dire qu'on veut que ces images soient
diffusées de réagir parce que c'est
aussi ça qui est très étrange avec cette
durée du procès c'est que nous on a
témoigné à quatre mois et demi depuis
notre parole n'existe plus elle est
substitué par nos avocats d'accord mais
donc faire ses demandes dire que c'est
important pour nous dire que nous on
pense que ça peut ouvrir une fenêtre
avec les accusés c'est une manière de ne
pas être dans la passivité et être dans
l'action vous aviez vous avez il y à un
mois arthur des nouveaux signé une
tribune dans le monde d'aplomb à
rapatrier les enfants français détenu
les enfants de djihadiste français qui
sont des enfants français détenus dans
des camps au nord de la syrie notamment
par des kurdes pourquoi est ce que c'est
important pour vous de le dire et
pourquoi vous pensez que c'est aussi à
vous de le dire il ya deux choses au
nord de la syrie il ya ce écran avec les
enfants français et il ya aussi des
prisons dans lesquelles il ya des
jihadistes français dont certains ont
commis des crimes contre des français
notamment en étant geôliers et mon
impression c'est qu'avec ce procès qui
se passe bien on se fait un peu plaisir
on a la fierté de dire regardez on sait
combattre le terrorisme et que la
justice il faut avoir l'honnêteté de
dire qu on est en train de regarder des
faits qui ont été préparés il ya six ou
sept ans et que ce qui est en train de
se passer au nord de la syrie avec des
enfants français à qui finalement on nie
tout droit à qui on nie tout humanisme
mais qui ont un passeport français on
est en train de les faire grandir dans
la haine de la france et on est aussi en
train de dire quelque part soyons fiers
de notre justice à ce procès mais
balayons toussaint à revers de la main
et soyons dans une forme de vengeance
vis-à-vis des enfants de nos bourreaux
et ça je pense que c'est un message que
les victimes peuvent porter qui est de
dire si on veut la justice si on va être
fiers de notre système de justice il
faut pas que ça s'arrête à la salle
d'audience il faut aussi que ça concerne
c'est en formant comment vous comprenez
qu'à ce jour la politique de la france
soit celle ci c'est à dire il ya que
quelques enfants qui ont été rapatriés
n'ya aucune politique générale ce que
d'autres pays pour le coup on fait
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
il ya une complexité liée au nombre il
ya une complicité est lié aussi au fait
que certaines mamans ne veulent pas se
séparer de leur enfant et ainsi de suite
mais il ya quand même surtout une peur
politique qui est dictée par des
sondages d'opinion et j'entends bien que
la majorité des français n'est pas pour
le rapatriement de ses enfants
je pense que c'est une manière un peu
populiste de regarder les choses si on
commence à se faire dicter notre
humanisme par les sondages on remettra
la peine de mort demain et donc c'est
aussi pour ça que c'est important de
rappeler que la justice arrête pas à la
salle d'audience et qu'il faut faire
preuve de ce qui est dans notre
déclaration des droits de l'homme
partout merci c'est chouette de
s'arrêter sur la déclaration des droits
de l'homme bonne journée à vous à
remercier nouveau merci beaucoup d'être
venu ce matin sur le plateau de paris
direct et donc ce pour ce je vais y
arriver ce procès devant la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris qui se
poursuit bien sûr merci encore on se
retrouve juste après la pause nous avec
d'amérique hockey a tout de suite